HONEYWELL FACILITY.
BRIAN: THAT’LL BE GREAT, THANKS
SO MUCH, GRIFF.
MEANWHILE LET’S BRING IN
KELLYANNE CONWAY, COUNCIL TO THE
PRESIDENT, HELPED HIM ELECTED IN
2016, KELLYANNE, WELCOME BACK.
I SEE THE PRESIDENT IS OUT
VISITING HONEYWELL AND I’M
STRUCK BY THE REPORT THAT CAME
OUT THAT NEW YORK TIMES GOT A
HOLD OFF PUT OFF BY FEMA WITH
715 PEOPLE LOSE LIVES TO THE
COVID-19, THAT’S GOING TO GO UP
TO 3,000 BY JUNE 1ST, THAT’S 71%
INCREASE, ARE THOSE THE NUMBERS
THAT -- THAT YOU HEARD AROUND
THE WHITE HOUSE TOO?
>> THE WHITE HOUSE CLEARLY SAID,
BRIAN, GOOD MORNING, THAT THE
TASK FORCE DID NOT GENERATE THE
DOCUMENT AND NO ONE AT THE TASK
FORCE TO MY KNOWLEDGE HAS BEEN
ASKED TO REVIEW IT ANDREW: SCRUB
THE DATA AND AGREE WITH IT.
I THINK THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
TO NOTE IS THAT THE PRESIDENT
HAS SAID ALL ALONG THAT WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE DEATH AND
DESTRUCTION.
WHAT WE HAVE BEEN TRYING TO DO
HERE IS TO MOURN THE DEAD AND
GRIEVE WITH THOSE WHO LOST LOVED
ONES AND MITIGATE THE DAMAGE
FROM THE INVISIBLE ENEMY.
JOINING FORCES WITH COMPANIES
LIKE HONEYWELL TO DEVELOP
HIGH-QUALITY N-95 MASKS,
RESPIRATORS, DEPLOYING THE
VENTILATORS TO EVERY STATE,
EVERYBODY NEEDED A VENTILATOR
GOT A VENTILATOR.
WORKING WITH DEMOCRATIC GOVERNOR
WHO IS ARE ACCREDITING HIM AND
LOBBYING EFFORTS TO COLLABORATE
WITH THEM AND NOT COMPETE WITH
THEM.
DEALING WITH THE OTHER G7
LEADERS WHO SAY IT’S A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC, REPATRIATING AMERICANS
WHEN THE PANDEMIC, THREE
CONSECUTIVE PACKAGES AND THE
PRESIDENT IS GOING TO CONTINUE
TO DO THAT.
WE KNOW THAT ADDITIONAL DEATHS
SADLY WILL CONTINUE.
WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO DO IS TO
SHOW THAT THE HEALTHCARE
PRESIDENT IS THE ONE THAT’S
GOVERNING AND DIRECTING HIS FDA
TO APPROVE PHARMACEUTICALS AND
DEVICES IN RECORD TIME,
SOMETIMES IT WOULD TAKE 4 TO 6
YEARS, IT’S DONE 4 TO 6 WEEKS.
SAME THING WITH HHHS AND CMS,
HOSPITAL RULES AND REGULATIONS
HAS BEEN RELAXED.
THIS PRESIDENT 100 BILLION NOW
PLUS FOR THE HOSPITALS FOR
REIMBURSEMENT, THAT’S
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF MONEY
BECAUSE ABOUT A THIRD OF THAT IS
GOING TO COVER COVID EXPENSES
FOR THE UNINSURED.
THIS HEALTHCARE PRESIDENT
STARTED WITH TRANSPARENCY,
MEDICAL BILLING, KIDNEY HEALTH,
DECREASING MEDICARE PREMIUMS BUT
NOW THE NATIONAL GUARDS ARE
SANITIZING NURSING HOMES AND NOW
THE VA HAS TESTED ALL OF THE
PEOPLE IN VETERAN SERVICING
HOMES AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO
BRING TESTING ONLINE AND THAT’S
WHAT WE ARE FOCUSED ON THAT THE
HEALTHCARE PRESIDENT CONTINUE TO
DELIVER FOR TIME OF PANDEMIC
CRISIS AND OTHER HEALTHCARE
NEEDS.
AINSLEY: KELLYANNE, TELL US WHY
HE DECIDED TO GO TO HONEYWELL,
HE’S FLYING TO OVER, WHY?
>> HONEYWELL HAS BEEN
PRIVATE-SECTOR PARTNERS THAT
STEPPED UP ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTRY, AINSLEY.
IN THIS CASE HONEYWELL COMMIT
TODAY AND IN FACT, DELIVERED ON
COMMITMENT TO PRODUCE
HIGH-QUALITY N-95 MASKS,
RESPIRATORS, WE HAVE COMPANIES
LIKE AMERICAN LEATHER THAT
CONVERTED FACTORIES IN NORTH
CAROLINA AND TEXAS TO TRY TO
HELP MAKE GOWNS AND MASKS AS
WELL.
WE HAVE TO SUCCESS STORIES ALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY EVERYDAY
AMERICANS CHECK ON ELDERS IN
THEIR LIVES, THEIR NEIGHBORS,
DONATE TO THE FOOD BANKS, TO THE
BLOOD BANKS, PEOPLE ARE REALLY
COMING TOGETHER AND TURNS OUT
THAT AMERICANS CAN BE PART OF
THE SOLUTION FOR SOMETHING AS
SERIOUS AS THIS GLOBAL PANDEMIC.
WE FOLLOWED INSTRUCTIONS, WE
SLOWED THE SPREAD FOR 45 DAYS
AND NOW AS WE GRADUALLY AND
SAFELY REOPEN IN ABOUT 35 OR SO
OF THE STATES, DEMOCRAT AND
REPUBLICAN STATES, WE PUT OUT
ALMOST 3 WEEKS AGO AINSLEY,
STEVE AND BRIAN, OUR THREE-PHASE
APPROACH TO SAFE, GRADUAL WE
OPEN.
THE STATES HAVE THAT.
OUR HEALTH TEAM AND ECONOMIC
EXPERTS HAVE TOLD EVERYBODY
PRESENT YOUR PLANS TO US, SHARE
THEM WITH US AND WE WILL SEE IF
THEY COMPORT WITH THE GUIDELINES
AND HOW BEST TO SUPPORT YOUR
EFFORT.
STEVE: BUT ONE OF THE
GUIDELINES, KELLYANNE, IF YOU
WANT TO ENTER PHASE 1, YOU TO
HAVE TWO WEEKS WHERE YOU GOT
NEGATIVE GROWTH OF THE VIRUS
AND, YOU KNOW, YOU LOOK AT THE
STATES THAT ARE REOPENING, IT
DOESN’T SEEM LIKE THAT IS THE
CASE.
>> SO I THINK SOME STATES ARE
REOPENING IN SOME AREAS AND
LET’S TAKE FLORIDA, FOR EXAMPLE,
GOVERNOR DESANTIS WAS LAST WEEK,
3 HARD-HIT COUNTIES AS I
UNDERSTAND.
THEY ARE HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS
OF MILES AWAY FROM SOME OF THE
BEACHES THAT REOPENED IN THE
NORTHERN PART OF THE STATE.
I THINK YOU’LL SEE EXAMPLES LIKE
THAT ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
ALSO IT DEPENDS ON THE INDUSTRY
AND THE INDIVIDUALS.
IF YOU ARE 72-YEAR-OLD WORKER
WHO HAD EXPOSURE OR WHO HAS
UNDERLYING CONDITIONS, YOU MAY
NOT GO BACK TO WORK PERHAPS AS
QUICKLY ASSAY SOMEBODY 30 YEARS,
40 YEARS YOUNGER THAN YOU, LIVE
AGO LOAN, HEALTHY, ASYMPTOMATIC.
THAT’S ONE EXAMPLE.
THE OTHER EXAMPLE IS JUST TO
SHOW THAT WE -- WE AS A FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SUPPORT WHAT THE
STATES ARE DECIDING SO LONG THEY
ARE COMPORTING WITH THAT.
LET ME MAKE CLEAR SOME STATES
FLATTENED A LONG TIME AGO, SOME
STATES NEVER REALLY HAD THANK
GOD A BIG SURGE.
THEY HAVE BEEN FLAT ALL ALONG
AND IT WOULD BE HARD FOR THEM TO
DECREASE NUMBERS WHEN THEY’VE
BEEN FLAT FOR A WHILE.
BUT IF YOU DON’T SEE THE SURGE
AND THEN THAT’S WHY OUR MEDICAL
TEAM ALSO SAYS IT’S IMPORTANT
BECAUSE THERE WAS A BIG OUTBREAK
IN THE STATE A FEW MILES FROM
YOU BUT IT WAS A WEDDING, IT WAS
A NURSING HOME, A PRISON, WE ARE
KEEPING OUR EYE ON THAT AND IT
MAY NOT AFFECT YOU AS MUCH AS IF
IT WERE YOU IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD.
BRIAN: I UNDERSTAND THE HOUSE WE
WANTED TO SEE DR. FAUCI, WHAT
COULD YOU TELL US ABOUT ANY
MEMBER OF THE TASK FORCE AND
TESTIFYING SOME TIME IN MAY AND
CAN YOU SEPARATE THE CHAMBERS?
YOU HAVE A DIFFERENT POLICY PER
CHAMBER?
>> LAWYERS ARE PROBABLY SORTING
THAT OUT.
I PREFER THAT OUR HEALTH AND ALL
OF US EXPERTS FOCUS CONTINUE TO
FOCUS ON THE PANDEMIC WHICH HAVE
BEEN DOING FOR 2 STRAIGHT MONTHS
AT THE WHITE HOUSE RATHER THAN
--
BRIAN: THEY SAY THEY ARE FROM
GETTING THE LATEST FROM THE TASK
FORCE.
>> THAT’S SURE, IF THE PRESIDENT
HAS NO PROBLEM, THERE’S NO
ATTACHMENT TO THAT, I WILL LEAVE
TO LAWYERS AND TESTIFIERS.
I THINK IT WOULD SHED GREAT DEAL
OF LIGHT.
I DO HOPE THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
ASKING THE QUESTIONS ARE ASKING
INTELLIGENT RATIONAL QUESTIONS
THAT ARE RELEVANT TO THE
AMERICAN HEALTH BECAUSE WE HAVE
SEEN WHAT THEY DO BEFORE, FOR
EXAMPLE, THEY SAY STUPID THINGS
LIKE THIS IS A JOB INTERVIEW,
THIS IS A JOB INTERVIEW FOR
LIFETIME APPOINTMENT FOR BRETT
KAVANAUGH, LET’S BELIEVE ALL
WOMEN, 3 WOMEN, MOST OF WHOM
RETRACTED OR DIDN’T HAVE
CORROBORATED EVIDENCE.
LET’S MAKE SURE THEY MAKE GOOD
USE OF QUESTION TIME OF DR.
FAUCI AND OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
TASK FORCE WE HAD TWO YEARS OF
COLLUSION NONSENSE, WE TRIED TO
REMOVE HIM AND NONE OF ALL OF
THAT WORKED IT BETTER BE ABOUT
HEALTH.
BRIAN: PRETTY CLEAR, THE
PRESIDENT SAID NO, THE WHITE
HOUSE SAID NO TO ANTHONY FAUCI
TO THE HOUSE AND I THOUGHT YES
TO THE SENATE AND YESTERDAY
SEEMED CLOUDY.
SENATOR SCHUMER INDICATED HE
WILL BE COMING TO THE SENATE, DO
YOU KNOW IF THAT IS TRUE, HE
WILL BE GOING TO THE SENATE AND
NOT GO TO THE HOUSE?
>> NO, I’M NOT GOING TO SAY THAT
TODAY ONE WAY OR THE OTHER.
IT’S UP TO THE PRESIDENT AND THE
LAWYERS HERE.
IF THEY WERE TO SAY YES TO THAT
SEN I CERTAINLY HOPE PEOPLE
WOULD MAKE GOOD TIME.
SPEND THE TIME IN RELEVANT
FASHION ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN HEALTH SO THAT YOU HAVE
THE INFECTION DISEASE LEAD FOR
THE COUNTRY AND THE TASK FORCE
THERE TALKING ABOUT THE TASK
FORCE WORK AND SAYING THAT THE
MITIGATION TACTICS WE ALL
UNDERTOOK HAVE ACTUALLY HELPED
THE SPREAD.
I HEARD DR. FAUCI SAID THAT
PUBLICLY AND PRIVATELY.
LOOK, DR. FAUCI HAS MEETING
DAILY AND HAS GREAT EXPOSURE TO
THE COUNTRY IN TERMS OF HELPING
THEM UNDERSTAND THE PANDEMIC AND
WHAT TO DO TO PROTECT THEMSELVES
AND OTHERS.
SOMETIMES AS QUESTIONS ARE
RELEVANT AND SOMETIMES THEY ARE
NOT.
IT’S JUST A COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO
YOU HAD A REPORTER FROM
DIFFERENT NETWORKS BASICALLY
SHOUTING HIM ABUSIVELY ACTING
HIM OF BEING A SUPPLICANT, ARE
YOU HERE ON YOUR FREE WILL, SO
LET’S JUST MAKE SURE IF HE DOES,
HE IF CAN, BUT I THINK THAT OUR
WORK IS VERY CLEAR EVERY DAY TOO
FROM THE TASK FORCE.
YOU’VE HAD THE TASK FORCE
BRIEFINGS, WE’VE MADE OUR
DOCTORS, ECONOMISTS, VICE
PRESIDENT HIMSELF, CABINET
MEMBERS AVAILABLE TO THE PRESS
AND AVAILABLE TO THE PEOPLE
QUITE REMARKABLY IF NOT
HISTORICALLY AND TRANSPARENTLY.
AINSLEY: KELLYANNE LET’S TALK
ABOUT MICHAEL FLYNN.
WE ARE LEARNING NOW THE FBI HAD
PIENKA, WHAT DO YOU KNOW ABOUT
IM, THE GUY THAT WORKED ON THE
FBI AND ALSO PARTICIPATED IN THE
RUSSIA COLLUSION AND -- AND
SURVEILLING CARTER PAGE’S PHONES
AND THIS IS JIM JORDAN BECAUSE
JIM JORDANS WANTS SOME ANSWERS
AN HE’S ASKING FOR CHRISTOPHER
WRAY TO SPEAK ABOUT THIS,
LISTEN.
>> JIM: WHERE HAS CHRIS WRAY
BEEN?
WE WANT TO TALK TO AGENT THAT IS
WERE THERE WHEN THEY INTERVIEWED
MIKE FLYNN AND WHY THEY CHANGED
THE 302.
LET US TALK WITH MR. PIENKA WHEN
THEY INTERVIEWED MIKE FLYNN.
THAT’S WHAT WE WANT TO SEE.
AINSLEY: KELLYANNE ENLIGHTEN US,
TELL US WHO WAS IN THE ROOM WHEN
THE FBI INTERVIEWED MICHAEL
FLYNN WHEN HE DIDN’T HAVE AN
ATTORNEY THERE AND ATTORNEYS
RETWEETING A TWEET ABOUT
CHRISTOPHER WRAY, SHE WANTS HIM
FIRED.
>> I THINK SUNLIGHT IS THE BEST
DISINFECTANT AND WE SHOULD HAVE
IT ALL OUT THERE IN TERMS OF
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
OBVIOUSLY THE PRESIDENT IS
CORRECT MICHAEL FLYNN WAS
DENIGRATED AND AS HE TOLD NEW
YORK POST YESTERDAY PROBABLY
TREATED MORE UNFAIRLY THAN
ANYBODY ELSE AND HE’S RIGHT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, THE FBI,
THE OBAMA PEOPLE FRANKLY SENT
THEIR FOLKS, THE OBAMA-BIDEN
PEOPLE SENT FOLKS TO THE WHITE
HOUSE A FEW DAYS INTO OUR
ADMINISTRATION.
DID THEY COME HERE TO HELP?
DID THEY COME HERE TO WARN THAWS
MICHAEL FLYNN IS A RUSSIAN
ASSET?
NO, HE HAD BEEN THEIR COLLEAGUE.
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA, TWO
THINGS TO WORRY ABOUT NORTH
KOREA AND MICHAEL FLYNN.
THAT’S JUST ODD STUFF.
ARE THE TWO.
GENERAL WHO SERVED 3 PLUS
DECADES WITH DISTINCTION AND FOR
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION WHICH
CONTINUED GIVEN TOP SECURITY
CLEARANCE.
SO WE WILL FIND OUT WHO WAS IN
THE ROOM AND WHY THEY WERE
SETTING UP.
WE’VE ALREADY SEEN THE NOTES IN
THE MARGIN, SHOULD WE GET HIM TO
LIE OR BE FIRED, WE ALREADY KNOW
THAT THE FIX WAS IN AND I THINK
THAT WE ARE -- IF PEOPLE SAY,
OH, YOU’RE JUST TRYING TO
INVESTIGATE, FOLKS, WE WENT
THROUGH A 2-YEAR INVESTIGATION
ON YOUR TAXPAYER DOLLAR AND WE
COMPLY TODAY THAT IN THIS WHITE
HOUSE, NOTHING CAME OF IT.
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION, THE
MUELLER REPORT, THE MUELLER
TESTIMONY, REMEMBER THOSE?
AND THEN INTO THE UKRAINE
INVESTIGATION, WE HAVE EVERY
NEED TO KNOW TRANSPARENTLY WHAT
HAPPENED AND I DO THINK DIRECTOR
WRAY SHOULD SPEAK ALSO.
I THINK THE FORMER FBI DIRECTOR
WHO GOT A HEROS WELCOME, JIM
COMEY’S BOOK, THE PRIME TIME
INTERVIEWS, HE LIED TOO.
HE’S A LIAR AND A LEAKER, HE
LIED AND LEAKED.
HIS BOOK IS A ROLL OF PAPER
TOWELS AT THIS POINT.
I WANT TO HEAR ALSO THE PEOPLE
AT THE TOP, THE FBI WHO TRIED TO
PREVENT DONALD TRUMP FROM BEING
ELECTED WERE POLITICAL IN THEIR
JOBS ON TAXPAYER DOLLAR.
THEY CONTINUE TO DO THAT AFTER
HE GOT ELECTED AND IN THE EARLY
DAYS OF OUR ADMINISTRATION
THROUGH MICHAEL FLYNN, NEWLY
INSTALLED NATIONAL SECURITY
DIRECTOR.
WE NEED TO KNOW.
STEVE: KELLYANNE, BEFORE YOU GO,
BREAKING NEWS, YOU KNOW, DOWN IN
VENEZUELA NICOLÁS MADURO SAID
HIS GOVERNMENT CAPTURED TWO
AMERICANS, WE BELIEVE THEY COULD
HAVE BEEN SPECIAL FORCES.
HE REFERS TO THEM AS MERCENARIES
AND HE SAYS THEY WERE IN HIS
COUNTRY TO TRY TO KILL HIM.
WHAT -- WHAT’S THE WHITE HOUSE
STORY ON THAT?
>> I WILL LET THE NATIONAL
SECURITY FOLKS IF NOT THE
PRESIDENT TO TALK ABOUT THAT, I
WILL
-- WILL BE LEAVING SHORTLY AND
MAKE TAKE QUESTIONS FROM THE
PRESS.
WE DON’T BELIEVE MADURO IS
LEGITIMATE PRESIDENT AND
SECRETARY OF STATE AND OTHERS
HAVE SAID AND I WANT TO SAY WHEN
THE PRESIDENT VISITS ARIZONA ONE
OF THE THINGS IN HONEYWELL
THAT’S SIGNIFICANT, HE’S HAVING
A ROUND TABLE WITH NATIVE
AMERICANS, HE WILL BE SIGNING A
NEW PROCLAMATION FOR MISSING AND
MURDERED INDIGENOUS WOMEN.
WE HAD A BIG EVENT HERE IN THE
OVAL OFFICE THE END OF NOVEMBER.
WE ALSO HAVE INVESTED OVER
$8 BILLION IN THE TRIBAL LANDS
DUE TO COVID-19, MAJOR
INVESTMENT BECAUSE THEY AND
OTHER VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
HAVE BEEN DISPROPORTIONATELY
HARD HIT AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THE PRESIDENT IS THERE TO
SPEAK WITH THEM DIRECTLY.
WE WILL KEEP YOU POSTED ON
VENEZUELA SITUATION AS IT